oh hi did you ever I want to play a
Grand Theft Auto style sandbox game in a
big city where your character was
actually a superhero and could jump off
of buildings and climb up buildings and
all kinds of crazy stuff yeah so tonight
it was called crackdown for the Xbox 360
and it was really good I loved it you
know who also loved it Sony because
they're making a game for the
PlayStation 3 very very similar to
crackdown but actually from our
experience quite a bit better than it's
called infamous now infamous feels quite
a bit like that other open-world
superhero game but it's a lot more
polished and it has broader gameplay and
a much deeper story that lets you choose
between good and evil
here's the story in a nutshell your coal
an explosion granted you the ability to
control electricity and kill dudes by
throwing lightning at them also your
city has fallen into Anarchy and you're
one of the only things that can stop the
bad guys from totally taking over the
place you can climb up buildings you can
jump off roofs you can fly a little bit
and you can wreak all kinds of havoc
infamous is immediately fun getting to
explore a city vertically as well as
horizontally jumping from building to
building and finding upgrades for your
lightning Bowers is probably going to be
really addictive I was able to try a few
different missions in the preview
version that Sony gave us and these have
you doing all kinds of things my
favorite was taking out armored buses
that are driving around massacring
people you can't get up close to them or
they're gonna shoot and kill you so
you've got to leap off a roof when one
drives by land on top and then overload
the power source
I mean hey at least terrorists use
electric buses in the future right many
missions let you choose between good and
evil options in this early mission once
you get your hands on some food you can
decide either let the good people have
it or well this for a long time I'll get
this all out of here pronto hey Trish
what's wrong with you people are
starving and you're stealing the only
food they've seen
food will be all ours some of these guys
might starve so what's the difference
between good and evil well it changes
the game's storyline of course making
people react to you very differently but
it also alters the powers that you can
have some of the crazy lightning based
powers that you can unlock are only for
good characters and some are only for
bad guys a meter in the corner of the
screen shows you where you're at
morality wise I've only gotten to play a
few snippets of infamous but I can't
wait for the rest it will be available
only on PlayStation 3 on May 26